how long have you been on this journey
now rich how long would you say red pill
aware
so
i think the books that open up the can
of worms for me were probably
rollo's first book
second book
and then the evil psych stuff that i got
into as well
um
and all of it was just like okay
i you know i get it now and um
now i understand why things are the way
they are i mean they mostly deal with
women right but
i was having a conversation with a guy
the other day
on a zoom in one of the business um
groups that i run
and you know he was talking about how
he is basically making approaches
to
prospects
and they're not really giving him the
time of day they're
they're somewhat frigid you know towards
them
and they basically rush them off and you
know this is a guy that's in the group
and he's red pilled and he knows about
women in cold approach and he was
telling me about his poa stuff at one
point so i said to my go you know it's
not that much different than dealing
with women in genuine burning desire
right like chapter three in my book i
talk about genuine burning desire and
why it's important and i said am i go
it's basically the same thing with these
pros prospects if they don't see the
value in inviting you into their
business to do something to solve a
problem you know for them they're not
gonna do it you know the same way a
woman that you might be interested in is
not interested back in you and has low
desire or she's indifferent or doesn't
care
she's not going to be responsive she's
not going to answer your uh phone call
she's not going to respond to your text
or email sort of thing same thing
these prospects don't have the level of
desire that you're looking for right we
kind of had to you know deal with
you know a few different areas after
that but the point that i'm driving at
here is that
you know the unplugging process brings
you to the truth the red pill and yeah
you can apply it to women but i've seen
myself apply it to every area of life
not just women self-care
finance everything too right so
um you know business transactions
interactions with people in business you
know colleagues in that area too so
um
i like to broaden the scope and it's
like you know i just don't take that i
mean i've got my i got my nighttime
pills over here because i gotta take
them you know before bed so i'm gonna
hold up my little capsule but you know i
just don't take you know the one pill
right i just like to spread that out in
all in all areas of my life and just say
you know let's take these cold hard
shoes and examine them in more than just
one area because i think that that the
the big mistake that
a lot of guys make is all they do is
they focus on chasing [ __ ]
it's it's not count notch got natch
count lays you know
you know one after the other it's like
that gets
it gets boring after a while you know
like it really does
right wow there's way too much focus in
that area and i think that's why a lot
of guys get get lost or they get
confused about next steps in life right
because they don't just see it as more
than just girls
no that's that's a good point i mean
it's not just
life after red pill awareness with women
it's life after red pill awareness with
in all aspects i think i probably was
thinking a bit more explicitly about
women okay
you you've become aware now what right
and there's definitely phases that i
think most guys go through where they
are
using the tools and getting good results
and there's kind of a crescendo and a
holy [ __ ] and
you know the first time that there's
that burning desire sex that just
just you know
i mean this is how
perverse my relationship was i had
convinced myself that i wasn't that
sexual
and that it wasn't that big of a deal
that my sex life with my wife sucked
and the first time i smashed afterwards
with real burning desire and she just
couldn't you know
fill in the blank keep her hands off me
whatever
yeah it blows your mind so of course
you're going to then want to go out
there and enjoy the candy for a little
bit but
you know after that what right after
that what for your business for your
life for your for who you're trying to
build as a person
but um
but how long have you said you would you
say you've been red pill rich has it
been
17 let's say 20 2016 2017 so it hasn't
been that long okay so yeah six seven
years so this will be you know
interesting to see
even you know the journey that you go on
too
and yeah where you land five years from
now ten years from now yeah yeah yeah i
mean i i
you know like i talk about it in the
intro my book where it's like you know
like the whole
sequence of events that led me up to
sort of taking the proverbial red pill
was beyond just women it was like
watching what the government was doing
with the regulations and how they were
dealing with financial institutions and
what they did to the industry that i
built the business in what happened
during the divorce machine what happened
after the divorce machine when i had
that relationship with a single mom and
it's like
a lot of our lives and time that we
spend as men is often you know tied up
around women you know because that's
that's why we're here on the earth right
i mean we're here to scatter seed right
like that's what we're doing that's it
but
there's a lot more to it than just that
and
stepping back from the whole women part
of thing and realizing that
you know there's a lot of different
spokes that keep a wheel up you know i
did this cast a month and a half two
months ago or something like that where
i was talking about the seven
main spokes that um are used to evaluate
your sexual marketplace value but you
know if you take a look at a wheel on a
bicycle it's got dozens of spokes i
don't know how many it's got in total 70
80 something like that i mean there's
there's multi facets to
unplugging from lies in life like one of
the things that i like to talk about
that is difficult to talk about on
youtube is
tying the unplugging process into things
like you know politics you know living
life um
you know choices in life when you're
dealing with women beyond just dating or
you know the typical smashing you know
conversation that comes up you know what
i'm saying
well i think
you're touching on an element too i have
not met
a dumb red pill aware person let's just
put it that way right i mean obviously
there's various degrees of achievement
and intellect but
everyone that i have interacted with any
substance
they're smart guys right they apply
patterns in their lives now they were
misapplying them for a while
i mean before they became blue pill
aware or a red pill aware but
um
you're spot on that you can't unsee it
and when you see that pattern you you
naturally start to apply in other places
and i would say the entrepreneurs that
come to the group
maybe even have a little bit of an
easier time because they have some red
pill awareness just from the reality
that you can't deposit into good
intentions in business right you can
only deposit results
so business
was the beginning of red pill for me
um but i just didn't realize it
yeah it's true you know because i'm in
the same boat i mean you know we're both
business owners and
that's that's uh that's kind of our own
personal origin stories but yeah i mean
you're absolutely right about that
that's uh
that's very true because when you do get
into
having to run your own thing and you
deal with things like lawsuits insurance
accountants taxes employee issues
you know like the list goes on and on
and on right like there's like there's a
realization at some point like oh [ __ ]
entrepreneurship isn't sugar and spice
and all things nice this is actually
hard
but i know why people do it
why not just is it hard but you know the
adage of business is easy people are
hard right yeah yeah yeah that's a
better way to assess it is is business
is is easy but the things that come at
you like people are hard yeah absolutely
which is back to the harsh reality of
red pill right the unconvenient truce
you know you don't close the cell you're
not getting the check you know this is
and the nice thing about business is
that you have the opportunity to
integrate quickly right you can try
things fail try new things fail try new
things fail which again is the origin of
the red pill and the manosphere right a
bunch of guys coming together comparing
notes sharing what worked what didn't
and and slowly
convalescing or
consolidating
around
these uh these truths that rollo and you
and others have have put into articulate
words and and ideas but again so like i
guess we're to wrap back to this
original topic
what is
life after red pill awareness and i
think what we're touching on here is
that it touches different parts of your
life in different ways hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you